[Music]
is alien life
really out there humanity
has wondered about it for decades
and according to scientists it might
finally be a reality
astronomers have discovered there could
be
life on venus does
this mean we finally meet aliens
could this help us discover other aliens
and what does this discovery mean for us
this is what if and here's what would
happen
if there's life on venus
might not be as alien as you think
the planet is roughly the same size as
earth and
its gravity is 91 of our planets
we always talk about mars being a
potential home for humans but
we shouldn't count out venus either and
if there is life on the planet could
this
speed up our process of making it our
new home
first let's look into why exactly
scientists think there might be life on
venus
it all has to do with phosphine
this is a colorless flammable and
explosive gas that's also pretty stinky
it smells like a mix of garlic and
decaying fish
[Music]
this gas can be found on earth and it's
dangerous to
everything that uses oxygen to survive
it was used as a chemical weapon during
world war one and
is a byproduct of cooking
methamphetamine
yeah this gas is not very pleasant and
it can be extremely deadly but now
astronomers have found that phosphine
might be
in venus's atmosphere
[Music]
at first glance this might seem like a
terrible thing because
this gas kills anything that breathes
oxygen
but that doesn't mean that life can't
exist
just because something doesn't require
oxygen doesn't mean it's completely
lifeless
inside venus's clouds of phosphine there
could be
anaerobic bacteria these are organisms
that
don't require oxygen to survive they
could be living on venus producing this
phosphine gas
keep in mind that all of this is not
fully verified yet but
astronomers have been keeping an eye on
venus for nearly all of 2020 and
this is what they think they've
discovered
so if this type of alien life really did
exist on venus
what would it mean for us humans
well when you first hear about alien
life you probably think about
martians with big heads and us being
able to shake their hands but
that wouldn't be possible with these
life forms on venus
as it stands right now we wouldn't be
able to see
any of the life on venus with our naked
eye it's
all bacteria and microbes and
with all that potential phosphine on the
planet it makes
visiting venus more dangerous for humans
than ever
so will we be meeting this life form
anytime soon
probably not
is this discovery still incredibly
exciting
absolutely
and sure it's discouraging that we
haven't found martians yet but
try not to be too disappointed when
discovering potential
alien life we should remember to expand
our ideas about
what exactly these alien life forms
could be
they don't necessarily have to be
something with two or four legs that
humans are able to interact with the
possibilities for potential alien life
are endless things we can't even imagine
yet
and who knows what this current life
form could turn into
it may start small but in millions of
years
we might see venus bloom into a planet
full of organic life
and life on venus might not be limited
to
organisms living in phosphine gas either
experts think that due to all the
extreme climates on the planet
life could form almost anywhere
and that goes for the rest of the solar
system too
with scientists discovering potential
life on venus
who knows what else is out there
researchers will just have to keep
searching
to find out speaking of researchers
one of the lead scientists who made this
exciting venus discovery
is on this week's what if disgust
we sit down with dr sarah seeger to talk
about
how she found this potential life on
venus and
what exactly it means for other life in
the solar system check it out